je suis très heureux
de pas le le mot le plus important je
suis très fier
de ce que nous avons vécu ensemble
pendant trois jours
je suis très fier parce que
naturellement il y avait
nos ministres nos députés nos sénateurs
au féminin et au masculin
parce qu'il y avait
nos parlementaires européens parce qu'il
y avait nos candidats
il y avait nos militants et les
responsables de nos militants
dans l'esprit de Guidel
qui est un esprit de
d'engagement d'enthousiasme
et de familière fraternité à peu près
quelque chose comme ça alors Jean-Yves
toi qui a été le principal élu de Guidel
je suis très très heureux que tu nous
aies rejoint j'ai été très content que
Hervé Marseille soit avec nous j'ai été
très content que
pierre la route du Roux était là j'étais
très content des débats que nous avons
eu qui étaient formidables
IAM sureau c'était
c'était un moment que je n'oublierai pas
c'était
une fierté et je suis très content
Pierrick tu nous ait amené Valérie qui
elle aussi a joué un rôle dans notre
histoire depuis longtemps
merci donc à tous
je voudrais vous dire que le
ce que vous savez notre
[Musique]
vitalité notre santé
notre
enthousiasme conquérant c'est évidemment
dans notre esprit on dit ça à Guidel ou
nous venons depuis 12 ans les
universités de rentrée Thierry on en a
fait quelques-unes ensemble c'était
depuis plus longtemps que ça et donc
avec prudence je ne donnerai pas le
chiffre exact
mais c'est une réponse à tous ceux qui
imaginaient que
notre ce qui était programmé c'était
notre disparition
l'idée que il y avait deux blocs
que ces deux blocs exercés ensemble
et l'un après l'autre le monopole du
pouvoir
et qu'il n'y avait pas de place pour
ceux qui
affirmaient que la vocation de la
démocratie
c'est le pluralisme
et que la condition du pluralisme
c'est pour sortir de la bipolarisation
qu'il y ait au centre de la vie
politique française une formation et un
socle puissant
ça a été un combat
qui a été mené
contre nous
et par nous et au bout du compte ce
combat on a le résultat tous ensemble
sous les yeux dans la chaleur de cette
salle ce combat nous l'avons gagné c'est
pas le seul qu'on évoquera aujourd'hui
d'autres combats que nous avons gagné et
que Thierry a évoqué magnifiquement dans
la conception européenne la conception
de l'Union européenne ce combat là nous
l'avons gagné et c'est un combat
précieux vous vous souvenez que
on disait il y a deux blocs et dans
chaque bloc au fond tout le monde pense
à peu près la même chose
à quoi nous répondions
si vous dites qu'on pense la même chose
vous dites en même temps qu'on ne pense
plus rien
et
cette cette
affirmation là
qui était celle que nous articulions
hier que nous articulons aujourd'hui et
que nous articulerons demain cette
certitude là que la clé du pluralisme et
dans l'existence c'est-à-dire la clé de
la reconnaissance de chacun la clé de
l'acceptation des différences
la clé de de la compréhension mutuelle
entre des sensibilités des philosophies
des doctrines qui sont différentes c'est
dans l'existence de ce socle central
qui réunit cher Jean-Yves des femmes et
hommes de bonne volonté que nous aurions
dû réunir depuis longtemps un message
personnel pour Jean-Yves Le Drian
parce que nous avons beaucoup évoqué
cette perspective
et puis ça s'est pas fait parce que
c'est plus et je dis ça Bernard Guetta
aussi qui voit ce que je veux dire nous
avons beaucoup évoqué cette perspective
et
on n'avait pas réussi à le construire et
c'est grâce à l'élection d'Emmanuel
Macron à la présidence de la République
et à l'alliance que nous avons contracté
avec lui que cette réalisation
de la garantie du pluralisme par
l'existence d'un centre qui refuse la
bipolarisation que nous avons réussi à
rendre je crois à la démocratie
française le plus grand service qu'on
pourrait qu'on pouvait lui rendre
[Applaudissements]
et il y a un autre service que
maintenant nous devons lui rendre à
notre démocratie à notre société à notre
pays
c'est l'obligation dans laquelle nous
sommes de rejeter
ce pessimisme qui nous détruit de
l'intérieur
de rejeter le sentiment d'impasse
généralisé dans lequel les dans lequel
les Français se trouvent et
singulièrement les jeunes français ce
qui est un crime
contre contre notre peuple contre eux
contre la société que nous avons à
construire
réfuter
le sentiment d'une fatalité qui conduit
en réalité
Marc l'a dit à un effondrement prochain
et si nous prenons sérieux ce qui est en
train de se passer
le poison
d'un pessimisme généralisé
qui conduit à penser que
l'humanité n'est pas la solution que
l'humanité et le problème
faut pas s'étonner que ça ait des
conséquences directes dramatique
irréparable si ça a duré trop longtemps
c'est
l'effondrement de la démographie
française qui avait tenu bon plus
longtemps que les autres sur l'ensemble
du continent européen cet effondrement
de la démographie n'est que le symptôme
du découragement que peu à peu nous
laissons installer dans la société et
dans la démocratie et dans la démocratie
française et c'est donc là la
précisément notre responsabilité de
réinsuffler je veux pas dire seulement
de l'optimisme je veux dire de la
volonté de la détermination de la
résolution et au fond une vision
positive de l'avenir que pour l'instant
qui pour l'instant manque tant c'est à
cela que je voudrais consacrer cette
intervention en essayant mode de
respecter je te promets le temps de
parole que tu m'as accordé
et que je ne précise pas comme ça
il y a pas de risque
ça n'est pas tout à fait par hasard que
j'ai été pendant très longtemps tout
seul
le défenseur de l'idée de planification
ou de retour de la planification dans
notre mode de gouvernance alors j'avais
eu nous avions eu des ancêtres illustres
Jean Monnet en particulier mais notre
conviction et quand on voit fonctionner
les autres si
Marc l'a évoqué en un mot quand on parle
avec les dirigeants chinois dont je ne
partage pas les orientations
idéologiques ni même les méthodes enfin
c'était intéressant de voir ce que
pensent les dirigeants du peuple pour
l'instant le plus nombreux de la planète
même si ça ne va pas durer pour des
raisons là encore parfaitement clair la
Chine va perdre
dans les 30 ans qui viennent
l'équivalent de la totalité de la
population européenne
c'est un s'il y a un tsunami celui-là
est en tsunami
et donc quand on leur parle on parle à
30 ans
et on s'aperçoit que eux qui avaient
choisi la politique de l'enfant unique
ils ont essayé d'en sortir et il n'y
arrive pas pour l'instant
parce que quand vous êtes dans une
société quand vous avez grandi quand
vous êtes né pour nous on dit politique
de l'enfant unique comme si on pensait à
nos familles avec un enfant unique
et ça va très bien
mais quand il n'y a que des enfants
uniques
vous n'avez ni frère ni sœur ni oncle ni
tante ni cousin il n'y a que ce lien
vertical
c'est très difficile à porter au début
mais après quand vous y êtes habitué
vous reproduisez ce modèle dans votre
propre vie et c'est pourquoi en effet
les autorités chinoises ont de ce point
de vue là du souci à se faire notre je
voudrais
donc reprenant ce fil de de l'optimisme
vital sans lequel il est impossible
qu'un peuple choisisse son avenir et se
développe reprenant ce fil je voudrais
avec vous énumérer cinq défis
et puis conclure le plus vite possible
cinq défis le premier de ces défis nous
devons remettre la France dans le fil de
la production
parce que c'est le seul moyen
pas seulement d'être économiquement
vigoureux c'est le seul moyen de sauver
notre modèle social
personne ne se rend compte en tout cas
on le dit pas c'est devenu tellement
habituel personne ne se rend compte de
l'originalité extrême de la singularité
absolue du modèle social que la France a
construit après le Conseil National de
la Résistance
personne ne se rend compte dans nos
débats dans nos
combats politiques de de
l'incroyable choix d'un pays qui a
décidé qu'on allait prendre en charge la
totalité des services publics pour la
totalité de des citoyens pour la
totalité de leur vie
il n'y a pas de pays dans
monde le monde le monde le monde le
monde comme ça les autres pays vivent
sur un modèle complètement différent qui
est le modèle du chacun pour soi
tu paies l'éducation de tes enfants si
tu en as les moyens
tu cotises pour ta retraite par
capitalisation si tu en as les moyens tu
paies ta sécurité sociale et avant
d'entrer à l'hôpital on te demande ta
carte bleue
tu
t'assures contre le chômage et cela a
émis à la charge de chacun des citoyens
nous c'est un modèle complètement
différent c'est pas le modèle du chacun
pour soi c'est le modèle du tous pour un
et si l'on veut sauvegarder le modèle du
tous pour un élu issus du Conseil
National de la Résistance il y a deux
conditions
un que nous soyons assez nombreux pour
que ceux qui cotisent et ceux qui paient
des impôts puissent permettre d'assumer
cette charge et deux que le pays soit du
point de vue de la production
suffisamment efficace pour que cela soit
soutenu par un mouvement économique qui
permette cette solidarité là
et la France a décroché de avait
décroché depuis si longtemps du modèle
de la production on a connu des théories
d'entreprises qui disaient faut des
entreprises sans usine
on a accepté les délocalisations en
réalité on les a acceptés parfois on les
a voulu
on a on sait éloigné de cette guerre
d'influence qui consiste à avoir des
technologies elle est sauvegarder à les
protéger à les répandre tout ça on a et
ça se traduit là dans notre commerce
extérieur
ça se traduisait jusqu'à maintenant dans
notre commerce extérieur se traduisait
cruellement
puisque les études du plan l'ont montré
sur abondamment ces derniers ces
dernières années puisque nous étions
ça dure encore en nous étions à 650
millions de
déficits sur les légumes essentiels qui
nous permettent on a créé cet indice au
plan l'indice ratatouille monsieur le
ministre de l'Agriculture
il y a
cinq légumes le tomates les courgettes
les poivrons les oignons et les
aubergines
sur ces cinq légumes
650 millions de défis vous avez pas me
dire que la terre le climat le
savoir-faire français ne peuvent pas
produire ces cinq légumes là c'était 650
millions 2019
et c'est 750 millions cette année on a
pris ce simple exemple
parce que pour moi le on parle toujours
de production industrielle et du
caractère vert nécessaire de la
production industrielle mais pour nous
l'agriculture ça compte beaucoup et
c'est pourquoi Marc tu as une charge si
importante à nos yeux parce que après
l'Ukraine
après la guerre en Ukraine après
l'interruption
d'un certain nombre d'exportation ou
d'un nombre certain d'exportation de
céréales
quand on regarde nos marchés on peut
avoir une opinion mais quand on regarde
les marchés de l'Afrique on a plus
opinion on a une certitude
si s'interrompait
l'alimentation des marchés de céréales
africains de la part de la Russie
alors ce qu'on aurait c'est une crise de
famine multipliée selon coefficient
qu'on n'a pas connu qu'on a depuis
longtemps
cette
cette menace là
nous oblige à poser le problème alors je
reprends pas les domaines industriels
que Thierry est si justement illustré
mais
en agriculture ça a une conséquence
directe et aujourd'hui
encourageante
pendant très longtemps le dilemme la
question de ceux qui voulaient la
souveraineté alimentaire
dépendant de l'agriculture française le
dilemme était presque impossible à
résoudre et ça va vous évoquer en tout
cas à ceux qui ont suivi l'histoire il y
a quelques décennies des souvenirs
précis
garantir la production de votre pays et
accepter le risque des fluctuations les
années bonnes et les années mauvaises il
y a une loi il faut produire plus que ce
qu'on consomme RA
si vous acceptez le risque d'une année à
moins 20%. alors il faut que vous ayez
une production nettement supérieure à
votre consommation et hier
il y a quelques années encore récentes
c'était impossible comme dilemme à
résoudre c'était impossible parce que il
fallait stocker et vous vous souvenez
la Commission à l'époque elle commandait
de grands programmes de stockage on
faisait du beurre de la poudre de lait
qu'on distribuait à des prix cassés et
c'est pareil pour les céréales c'est
fini
désormais c'est ouvert devant nous une
autre logique les surplus que nous avons
ils peuvent servir à l'agro industrie
peuvent servir à l'agro chimie peuvent
servir les surplus en végétal et en
céréales ils peuvent servir à fabriquer
des carburants propres
peuvent servir comme matière première
pour
permettre la fabrication de substituts
aux matières plastiques et connaît plus
de matières plastiques qui ne peuvent
pas être dégradables et ceci pour moi
c'est une nouvelle
terriblement optimiste on a devant nous
des chances qui n'existaient pas avant
j'ai été très frappé j'espère que vous
l'avez été aussi par une étude qui a été
publiée sur la situation française
avant-hier par le Boston Consulting
Group
et le Boston Consulting Group qui est
sur les sur les sur les coûts
comparatifs et les concurrences
possibles il dit désormais en Europe la
première place en productivité
ça n'est plus l'Allemagne c'est la
France
je sais pas si si vous voyez ce que ça
veut dire
ce que ça veut dire comme réussite à
mettre à l'actif du gouvernement actuel
est-ce que ça veut dire comme révolution
dans les esprits nous la France nous
étions habitués à nous penser comme
inférieur
sur ces domaines là qui sont les
domaines de la vitalité économique et
puis une politique
pensée voulue cohérente
parfois incomprise
a fait que désormais en très peu
d'années nous avons retrouvé le niveau
qu'elle nous aspirions et c'est pas
éloigné Thierry de ce que tu as décrit
pour la politique européenne qui a été
de ce fait inspiré au sein de la
Commission européenne nous menons le
même combat
et ça n'est pas étonnant parce que nous
avons cette unité cette cohérence
doctrinale je vais dire philosophique de
de volonté d'affirmation d'un pays qui a
un modèle social exceptionnel et qui ne
peut pas parce qu'il veut soutenir ce
modèle social d'être absent de la
compétition mondiale et donc ça c'est le
ça c'est le premier défi et ce défi pour
nous il est évidemment très important
on sait bien que c'est un immense et
forme c'est un effort national et nous
allons le proposer et le faire vivre
deuxième défi
notre stratégie de développement durable
très souvent il y a évidemment des des
efforts si
important que
des courages quelquefois
le premier chapitre c'est l'émission de
gaz à effet de serre chapitre que tout
le monde reconnaît en fonction des
travaux scientifiques et si on veut une
politique de réduction continue de
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
de performance qui nous permet d'être
les moins émetteurs
dans le monde par rapport à notre
énergie notre production alors on sait
bien qu'elle est la clé cette clé que
nous avons les uns et les autres
défendus envers et contre tous
qui est la capacité de production
électrique du nucléaire français par le
nucléaire français le raisonnement que
nous avons défendu dans dans l'analyse
du plan qui a je crois jouait un certain
rôle dans la modification des esprits y
compris des esprits de décidèrent cette
analyse était très simple si on veut ne
plus émettre de gaz à effet de serre il
y a naturellement
la production d'énergie renouvelable
l'éolien
l'hydroélectrique
le solaire mais la caractéristique de
ces énergies renouvelables pour
l'immense majorité d'entre elles c'est
qu'elles sont intermittentes
le soleil brille pas tout le temps
l'électricité c'est très difficile à
stocker en tout cas dans ces masses là
quand j'étais jeune député que je me
battais sur ces sujets là
contre la prise d'athisation TDF je dis
ça au passage on s'en souviendra pas
mais en tout cas ça mériterait qu'on
s'en souvienne
on me disait
l'électricité
c'est comme les fraises des bois
ça ne se stocke ni ne se transporte
alors on a un peu progressé du point de
vue du transport
peut progresser du point de vue de
stockage tant qu'on ne maîtrisera pas la
production d'hydrogène par exemple
par électrolyse à grande à grande
échelle mais
une énergie intermittente
ça ne peut se compenser s'équilibrer que
par une production d'énergie pilotable
qu'on injecte quand on en a besoin il se
trouve que la seule énergie pilotable
non émettrice de gaz à effet de serre
c'est le nucléaire et il se trouve que
nous sommes parmi les premiers dans le
monde que nous étions
que nous étions parmi les premiers dans
le monde à avoir maîtrisé la technologie
de cette électricité là
et bien on est reparti on s'est remis
sur le sur le chemin et le président de
la République a fait un choix courageux
non seulement de maintenir mais de
développer l'énergie nucléaire et c'est
aussi le combat que nos parlementaires
européens et toi Thierry vous avez mené
dans le cadre européen pour que
l'énergie nucléaire soit reconnue comme
une énergie de transition
pour aller vers le vers le zéro émission
combat très difficile
donc j'espère qu'il ait gagné
et Thierry Breton fait oui de la tête
donc j'enregistre son oui sans réticence
j'espère qu'il ait gagné y compris du
point de vue de la considération
financière
que les crédits soient considérés comme
souhaitables et donc il y a là quelque
chose évidemment très important ça c'est
le premier enjeu il est majeur il y a un
deuxième enjeu si l'on veut équilibrer
c'est de réduire la consommation
quand on peut
sans perdre en
bien-être
parce que on va pas passer la marche
arrière et revenir à des temps où on
avait froid et même s'il fait de plus en
plus chaud peut-être faudra-t-il se
poser la question aussi de la
climatisation c'est comme ça qu'on va le
qu'on va le vivre or
des technologies existent et je veux
simplement dire ici un mot parce que
c'est très facile
si les esprits changent de la géothermie
nous vivons
debout sur une immense
chaudière
qui est
constamment créatrice de calories
gratuites
éternelle enfin éternelle à l'échelle de
l'humanité je sais pas si un jour
dans quelques milliards d'années cette
éternité sera limitée mais en tout cas
ce que je sais c'est que aujourd'hui
c'est immédiatement accessible aucune
des technologies c'est la technologie la
plus la moins polluante qu'on puisse
imaginer aucune des technologies n'est
difficile n'est inaccessible
aucune de ces technologies n'est chère
en tout cas cher à l'échelle d'un foyer
ou d'une famille
aucune nécessite des recherches
fantastiques mais ça nécessite trois
conditions donc le
[Musique]
98% du territoire 95% du territoire
français était éligible à la géothermie
il y a que quelques sous-sols qui sont
compliquées pour des raisons de
sécheresse et de
95% du territoire français
les économistes sont considérables
pour chauffer un logement si vous avez
une ressource en géothermie que ce soit
un immeuble ou que ce soit une maison
individuelle pour chauffer
80% d'économies d'électricité
avec une pompe à chaleur et de la
géothermie
pour
climatiser pour rafraîchir pendant l'été
l'économie est de 90% par rapport à un
climatiseur habituel et si vous vous
contentez de rafraîchir
rafraîchir ça veut dire sept à huit
degrés de moins que la température
ambiante que déjà beaucoup alors là
c'est 98% des économiques c'est
immédiatement disponible c'est demain
matin il y a aucune recherche
supplémentaire inférieure encore des
évolutions mais les pompes à chaleur
c'est là et les forages de géothermie
c'est Pau a été pendant des décennies la
capitale du forage en France parce que
nous avions comme vous savez le gaz de
lac on a l'école de forage en France
immédiatement accessible il faut trois
choses je disais info former des Foreurs
faut former 7000 forêts il y en a plus 1
2 il faut financer les appareils de
forage les foreuses c'est pas très cher
ça coûte 900
000 euros ce qui pour une entreprise PME
est tout à fait finança parce que ça
dure 20 ans
il y en a pas dans le Sud-Ouest il y a
un appareil de forage vous rendez compte
nous qui avons été le
les Foreurs de la planète un appareil de
forage et troisièmement faut trouver un
système de financement parce que la
différence entre entre cette
installation et une chaudière fioul ou à
gaz et de quelque chose comme 15000
euros mettons pour un pavillon faut le
financer parce que le retour sur
investissement est certain vous trouvez
avec la certitude dans 20 ans d'être
quasiment gratuit dans le fonctionnement
de votre chauffage ou de votre
climatisation pourquoi on le fait pas
c'est pour moi très très grand mystère
j'étais très content parce que le
Président de la République dans sa
dernière intervention a dit que il avait
créé une installation de géothermie à
l'Élysée et que désormais alors j'espère
que ça va faire école mais il suffit de
le vouloir parce que trouver un
instrument de financement soutenu par la
Caisse des Dépôts par exemple qui
permettent de dire aux gens ça ne vous
coûtera pas plus cher que l'installation
d'une chaudière à gaz tous les mois
pendant 15 ans ça règle la question et
ça nous permet d'économiser écoutez bien
on a calculé ça dans le rapport du plan
7 ou 8 tranches nucléaires dès l'instant
qu'on installe ça et vous voyez que ça
permet de faire le pont
entre le dans dans le temps
entre entre ce que ce que nous attendons
c'est-à-dire une production nucléaire
équilibrée et puis la situation
d'aujourd'hui troisième chose
il faut
concevoir la ville différemment
les mères qui sont là savent ce dont
nous parlons c'est à dire la loi sur le
zéro artificialisation nette
elle impose elle va imposer aux villes
de changer différemment de reconquérir
des friches de reconquérir des parkings
de supermarchés de construire dans les
zones pavillonnaires des appartements
surélévation avec double accès au jardin
tout ça c'est une idée une vision de
l'avenir des villes
et puis la biodiversité
Sarah
avec tout ce que vous envisagez c'est à
dire l'amélioration des biotopes c'était
formidable nos journées parlementaires
devant la porte du lieu très charmant
nous étions rural où nous étions de la
salle de réunion il y avait des lavandes
il y avait des milliers d'abeilles pas
des centaines des milliers d'abeilles
créer les conditions
du nourrissage des pollenisateurs pour
que nous retrouvions cette diversité
biologique c'est très important j'ai dit
quelque chose sur les haies à Sarah dans
le creux de l'oreille que je vais lui
dire maintenant publiquement
j'approuve monsieur le ministre de
l'Agriculture et Madame la Ministre de
de la biodiversité j'approuve
absolument l'incitation à planter des
haies
fournissez-nous des boutures
je connais des centaines de gens comme
moi qui peuvent planter des où est-ce
que je vais trouver les plans
si vous vous si vous que si on continue
si vous vous laissiez aller à continuer
ce que vous prédécesseurs ont fait c'est
à dire vanter les mais pas donner les
moyens aux gens de les planter parce que
le parce que les boutures et les plans
de de
c'est pas à quoi d'épineux que nous
avons besoin de mettre en place n'existe
pas alors c'est comme siffler dans un
violon et moi je propose que vous
preniez les choses en main le violon en
main et que vous produisiez les végétaux
gratuitement ou le moins cher possible
qui permettront à tout le monde de
planter des haies c'est l'esprit
pratique et d'exécution que Thierry
défendait à l'instant
je voudrais sur cette histoire du
développement d'érable aborder un
dernier point qui est plus délicat
mais je le fais en ayant conscience
qu'en effet c'est pas dans l'air du
temps
bien sûr on peut continuer il faut
continuer il est nécessaire de continuer
tous les efforts que la France conduit
pour arriver au standard que nous nous
fixons mais la France c'est le millième
de l'atmosphère de la planète et le
centième des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre tous les autres font pire
ont un bilan
infiniment plus inquiétant tous les
autres relances des centrales à charbon
notez ça
on vous raconte on nous raconte on nous
dit on soutient on trouve que le charbon
c'est à peu près la pire de ces énergies
avant le pétrole est loin avant le gaz
toute la planète relance les centrales à
charbon
et nous ne disons rien
et si vous croyez regardez la
Grande-Bretagne et ce qui s'y passe les
déclarations récentes du Premier
ministre
si vous croyez que les sociétés vont
accepter de concentrer les efforts sur
leur ressources propres alors que tous
les autres
renoncent et se servent de ces
renoncements pour être des concurrents
indépassables dans la compétition
internationale alors c'est que vous vous
mettez le doigt dans l'oeil jusqu'à
l'omoplate c'est pas comme ça que ça va
se passer c'est pas comme ça que ça va
se passer et donc
mesdames et messieurs les députés
européens
Monsieur le Commissaire européen
messieurs et mesdames les futurs
parlementaires européens
Mesdames et Messieurs les futurs
commissaires européens les futurs
ministres des Affaires étrangères les
futurs
chefs de gouvernement et les futurs
présidents de la République qui sont
dans la salle
nous avons une exigence
nous avons
je dis ça sérieusement nous avons une
exigence absolue de mener ce combat à
l'échelon international
parce que ça va s'effondrer
la volonté des peuples vertueux ne
résistera pas à l'effondrement
économique si les autres continuent à
faire le contraire de ce que on s'est
engagé à faire c'est une question
délicate elle remet bien des choses en
cause mais moi j'encourage à ce que nous
ayons le courage de la poser
troisième défi
et troisième optimisme
[Musique]
il faut que nous planifions l'idée de
revenir à l'équilibre des finances
publiques
[Applaudissements]
nous avons partagé vous avez partagé
avec moins 20 années de combat sur ce
sujet j'ai eu l'imprudence ou la folie
ce dont ce qu'on voudra de faire des
campagnes présidentielles sur le thème
du déficit de la dette
et la situation que nous avons
aujourd'hui
elle est inacceptable mais elle est
d'abord inacceptable moralement
parce que la responsabilité de ce des
générations
qui ont accepté
cette offense
au bon sens et à la responsabilité
de prendre pour eux tous les bénéfices
de tous les budgets de fonctionnement
des avantages matériels divers et variés
et qui laissent à leurs enfants la
charge de payer ses milliards de
fonctionnement c'est impossible à
supporter comme vous savez je suis allé
devant le corps le nom que vous savez
pas mais je vous raconte c'est écrit
dans les journaux mais en petit donc je
suis allé devant le corps le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites
pour
leur donner des chiffres précis sur un
débat que nous avons eu qui était
incroyable pour moi
les messages que l'opinion française
recevait du corps c'était les retraites
sont en excédent
donc
c'est pas la peine
de se casser
la volonté
[Musique]
et tous les Français l'ont cru
spécialement l'opposition parce que ça
les servait tellement mais un très grand
nombre de Français me dit mais François
pourquoi tu nous casses les oreilles
avec la réforme des retraites c'est un
excédent il est possible que en 2030 il
manque quelques milliards tu parles
c'est en équilibre
parce que
l'État le budget de l'État verse au
moins 40 milliards par an pour obtenir
cet équilibre ici j'ouvre une parenthèse
ou plutôt je mets une note en bas de
page
même si c'est dur à accepter un milliard
c'est 1000 millions
d'euros
alors je sais bien que l'arithmétique
est totalement disparu le calcul mental
qui est une science majeure parce que
c'est je suis sérieux c'est une science
civique c'est la science des ordres de
grandeur
c'est 40 000 millions d'euros que tous
les ans
qui tous les ans sont versés
au système de retraite pour obtenir
l'équilibre et ses 40.000 millions
d'euros mes amis
ils sont entièrement empruntés
ils sont
le tiers au moins au moins parce qu'il y
a des calculs encore plus pessimistes
mais je préfère garder des ordres de
grandeur de cet ordre
ils sont au moins le tiers
de des sommes que la France emprunte
chaque année et qui sont cette année de
127 milliards
127000 millions d'euros qu'on emprunte
et emprunter ça paraît agréable ou
facile
mais ceux qui vont rembourser
c'est les générations qui viennent et
personne ne remarque ou ne dit que cela
vont avoir une triple charge vont devoir
assumer leur propre vie de génération et
ça sera pas facile avec tous les
renchérissements que nous connaissons
ils vont devoir comme c'est normal dans
un système dit par répartition je dis
dit par répartition parce que les sommes
que je viens de dire explique que c'est
plus un système par répartition
mais ils vont devoir assumer les
pensions des retraités leur
contemporains et en plus
bourse les pensions que depuis 20 ans on
met à leur charge ceux-ci est une honte
c'est inacceptable c'est impossible
[Applaudissements]
et je suis j'ai été
tellement triste
que le gouvernement ne fasse pas la
vérité avec les Français sur une réforme
qui aurait été prise complètement
différemment et je vous dis quelque
chose que vous ne croirez pas à vous
direz comme toujours
il est il a un peu divergé moi je crois
qu'on aurait gagné un référendum sur ce
sujet je pense que en s'expliquant avec
les Français comme avec des co décideurs
comme avec des co-responsables ce qui
est notre vision de la démocratie que
j'ai expliqué hier soir à l'occasion
d'une d'une intervention fortuite moi je
crois que la démocratie ça consiste à
partager la responsabilité
c'est pas des gouvernants élus une fois
tous les 5 ans à qui on donne carte
blanche
pour qu'il fasse ce qu'il croit de voir
faire même honnêtement c'est plus comme
ça que ça fonctionne et l'argument de
dire c'était dans le programme dont on
l'applique c'est plus comme ça que ça
marche le il y a eu une exigence de
participer c'est un mot que comme vous
savez a eu sa fortune dans l'histoire de
la France exigence de participation du
citoyen
s'il n'y a pas je dis ça avec
toute la gravité nécessaire
cette mutation de méthode dans la
démocratie qui fait que les gouvernants
ne se sentent plus
légitime à décider sans l'opinion ou
contre l'opinion quelquefois faut aller
contre mais selon moi quand un sujet
crucial s'il faut aller contre l'opinion
il y a une arme c'est le référendum et
j'y viendrai dans une minute
cette idée que
sans le soutien de l'opinion ou au moins
la compréhension de l'opinion ou au
moins le respect de l'opinion vous ne
pouvez pas gouverner
cette idée là c'est à mon sens la seule
idée de sauvegarde de la démocratie
comme nous la défendons envers et contre
tout presque tout le reste du monde
envers tout ce qu'on appelle autoritaire
il libéraux nous nous défendons l'idée
de la responsabilité partagée avec les
citoyens alors c'est évidemment un
énorme enjeu que celui là et c'est vrai
pour l'ensemble des finances publiques
il n'y a qu'un moyen de s'en sortir et
vous allez là encore retrouver une
obsession il n'y a qu'un moyen de s'en
sortir c'est de faire un plan à long
terme de retour à l'équilibre parce
qu'évidemment vous pouvez pas le faire
d'un seul coup ça fait des chocs qui
entraînent des rejets et tout ça ne
marche pas
mais si vous dites voilà on se donne 10
12 15 années pour revenir à l'équilibre
ça demande des efforts si vous avez en
tête l'ordre de grandeur des chiffres
que j'indiquais
aller en 5 et 8 milliards par an des
forces supplémentaires
si nous faisons ça
alors les gens peuvent comprendre que
notre préoccupation est une
préoccupation sincère qu'on ne cherche
aucun avantage pour aucune situation
sociale ou économique particulière qu'on
cherche simplement à sauvegarder
l'équilibre des générations qui viennent
alors ça veut pas dire qu'on emprunte
plus
mais je préconise qu'on s'occupe de la
dette pour la seule chose qui compte
c'est à dire l'investissement
et pas la vie de tous les jours pas le
fonctionnement pas les retraites la
dette s'est fait pour investir Thierry
pour créer des capacités nouvelles pour
une nation et là dans les décennies qui
viennent de passer on a en ces temps
d'été pour le fonctionnement et on n'a
pas fait en termes d'investissement ce
qu'il aurait convenu ce qui aurait été
nécessaire de faire voilà le choix entre
la bonne dette et la mauvaise dette
voilà à mon avis ce qui appelle à cette
prise de conscience de ce troisième défi
et de ce troisième plan optimiste qui
est le retour à l'équilibre des finances
publiques quatrième plan ça vous
surprendra pas l'éducation
faut pas qu'on se trompe
le ministre l'a dit hier l'éducation en
France aujourd'hui et dans une crise pas
profondeissime
alors
ayant
largement annoncé exercée des
responsabilités annoncées ce qui allait
se produire notamment dans ce livre qui
a été cité hier à la tribune j'étais
très content que quelqu'un se souvienne
de ce livre qui a 30 ans qui s'appelait
la décennie des malapris
mais je me suis trompé c'était pas une
décennie des malapris c'était un
demi-siècle de malaprix
[Musique]
là aussi on a besoin d'un retour
à l'équilibre et il faut le faire pour
cette mère de toutes les batailles il
faut le faire de manière déterminée
quand vous vérifiez que 20% des enfants
qui entrent en 6e ne savent pas bien
lire et bien écrire
un enfant sur cinq
qui entre en sixième ne sait pas
bien lire ni bien écrire
vous vous dites que la France qui a été
le pays du monde considéré comme ayant
la meilleure éducation primaire
que ce pays-là rencontre des difficultés
qui sont inédites quand vous constatez
qu'il y a
un enfant sur deux
au collège
qui ne sait pas placé
la fraction 1/2 sur une échelle de 0 à 5
alors je parle même pas de la fraction
3/6
qui est la même mais
mais pour ça il faut
comme dit Victor Hugo ces choses-là sont
rudes il faut pour les comprendre avoir
fait des études
et donc cette cette notion là c'est une
notion terriblement inquiétante pour une
nation moderne
et quand vous regardez ce qui est ce que
un certain nombre d'entre nous aimons la
langue
la langue orale la langue écrite
l'orthographe alors l'orthographe
alors nous sommes devant des
responsabilités très importantes
et puis
quand vous parlez avec les enseignants
français de la classe de la tenue dans
la classe
vous avez exactement le même genre de
frayeur parce que vous ne pouvez pas
enseigner s'il y a pas
un calme minimal et une concentration
minimale dans la classe or aujourd'hui
c'est un problème qu'on ne sait plus du
tout traiter
et alors
il y a des raisons à tout ça je sais
très bien que l'omniprésence des écrans
sous les yeux et dans l'esprit des
enfants jouent un très grand rôle et
c'est pas moi qui suis un geek
depuis longtemps qui vais qui vais dire
le contraire les écrans ça peut être
formidable mais c'est comme la langue de
Monsieur Ésope ça peut être la meilleure
ou la pire des choses
et quand vous apprenez que dans la
silicone valait les dirigeants de ces
entreprises ont créé pour leurs enfants
chacun pour soi des écoles dont la règle
est simple et colle sans écran
parce qu'ils ont compris quelque chose
qui est difficile à accepter
c'est qu'on n'a pas la même capacité
d'absorption
d'apprendre de découvrir les choses
selon qu'on les reçoit passivement ou
selon qu'on va les chercher
c'est pas la même chose
et la lecture et l'écriture et la
conversation ça permet d'aller chercher
pour intégrer des connaissances et de la
compréhension du monde
donc toutes ces raisons là sont
naturellement valables alors
moi je crois
j'accepte d'être pris pour idéaliste je
crois que à l'école on peut redresser la
situation en très peu de temps
moi je crois qu'il on peut la redresser
en cinq années
et comment la redresser en 5 années
pour retrouver ce niveau de cette nation
école
je propose de partir du constat d'un
paradoxe que tous vous connaissez
l'école va très mal
mais tous nous connaissons des preuves
formidables
ils nous ont sauvé la vie quelquefois
souvent on a quelqu'un qui nous a sauvé
la vie qui nous a tendu la main qui a
permis de découvrir quelque chose
et il y a des profs formidables il y a
aucun problème personne ne sait qu'ils
sont
personne ne les repère et personne
n'essaie de s'inspirer de leur pratique
et de leur méthode
et moi je propose que ce soit sur ça
qu'on fonde le
la reconstruction la refondation de
notre école avec 5 années de cinq années
de perspective devant nous en repérant
ceux qui réussissent à faire progresser
leur classe quel que soit le niveau de
leur classe
il y a des partout des enseignants qui
prennent des élèves en difficulté et
qu'il les portent à un niveau qui
n'avait jamais espéré atteindre
repérons-le et allons étudier chacun
leur stratégie pédagogique pour essayer
de la répandre et de l'offrir au plus
grand nombre ceci est une révolution
pour l'école française c'est pas du
sommet que viendra là que viendra la
réponse je le crois c'est du repérage
des réussites modestes écoles par école
collège par collège et lycée par lycée
si on fait pas ça autrefois ça
s'appelait il y a très longtemps et d'un
mouvement différent les Cahiers
pédagogiques
c'est-à-dire des gens qui partagaient
des expériences alors ça a tourné un peu
différemment du point de vue de la
philosophie
d'enseignement mais c'est pour moi une
solution absolument certaine
deuxièmement
il faut que nous prenions en compte une
règle il faut apprendre à nager avant de
plonger
je le dis parce que j'ai moi-même
pratiqué
cet art de la plongée de manière
délibérée
c'est une plaisanterie vous n'êtes pas
obligé de rire non
mais
c'est pas possible qu'on laisse entrer
en sixième les élèves qui ne savent pas
lire
parce qu'ils vont pas rattraper
on va de classe en classe
faire que
il passe dans la classe supérieure
et au bout du collège ils seront
marginalisés éjectés ils arriveront pas
je suis je ne peux pas accepter l'idée
que nous ayons des enfants à qui nous ne
pouvons pas offrir cette reconstruction
dans les
dans les fondamentaux et c'est pareil
pour le calcul je crois mais consacrons
les moins nécessaires
au moment de l'entrée en 6e ou un peu
plus tôt pour réhabiliter pour offrir
une reconstruction à ceux qui sont
complètement dans la difficulté c'est
l'oeuvre peut-être la seule oeuvre ses
lèvres la plus sociale que nous devrions
envisager de faire si vous donnez pas ça
à un enfant vous le trahissez c'est de
la non-assistance enfant en danger et je
suis persuadé qu'on ne peut pas accepter
cette fatalité
[Applaudissements]
il y a une autre chose à faire je vais
pas me faire des amis il y a une autre
chose à faire
c'est
respecter les enseignants
alors
je vais
je vais vous dire quelque chose il y a
rien
qui m'agace alors c'est souvent
et je dissimule cette agacement parce
que c'est de mes amis souvent qu'il
s'agit de tous ceux qui disent les
enseignants ne travaillent pas assez
leur horaires de travail c'est pas
pareil dans les autres pays les autres
on peut les payer mieux parce que les
nôtres travaillent pas assez
moi je ressens ça alors je
suis évidemment concerné je ressens ça
comme une offense
comme quelque chose d'insultant
et
par exemple on demande jamais quel est
le temps de travailler effectif d'un
journaliste qui va présenter le journal
télévisé
il vient devant les caméras au maximum
20 minutes quelquefois 2 minutes pour un
reportage mais il travaille le reste du
temps on demande on ne pense pas qu'un
magistrat ne travaille pas assez parce
qu'il va
on ne parce qu'on ne décompterait que le
conte de que le temps de travail pendant
une audience
et les enseignants ils sont constamment
victimes de cette persécution là
et si quelqu'un maintient ça moi je
propose quelque chose que ceux qui
disent ça ils viennent 15 jours
devant une classe
[Applaudissements]
primaire devant un CM2 devant une
quatrième ou une classe de seconde qu'il
vienne avec la préparation des cours
qu'ils viennent avec les horaires
effectivement avec les corrections de
copies avec les conseils de classe avec
l'obligation de remplir les bulletins
avec la réception des parents et qu'ils
additionnent à la fin s'ils viennent me
dire j'ai été prof 15 jours en quatrième
et je travaille pas assez alors je serai
prêt à écouter leurs arguments autrement
qu'il nous écoute nous et qu'ils
écoutent les enseignants
parce que c'est pas si vous vous rendez
compte
d'abord on a une grande difficulté à
recruter
mais je vais vous dire un secret parce
qu'on le dit pas à voix haute les
enseignants s'en vont
aujourd'hui
et des enseignants brillants dévoués
engagés qui croient à cette idée là ce
sont pas soutenues
se sentent pas encouragés et ils s'en
vont et c'est cette grande désertion là
que normalement dans des mouvements
comme les nôtres qui sommes si
profondément attachés à l'école nous ne
devrions pas accepter et donc ça c'était
le quatrième défi il y a un cinquième
défi et j'en aurais fini puisque j'en ai
annoncé cinq
c'est
la refondation de notre démocratie de
notre action publique
et c'est pas le plus mince des défis
parce que là j'ai énuméré quatre ou cinq
problèmes mais vous pouvez prendre la
santé le logement le
la sécurité
tous ces problèmes dépendent dans un
pays comme la France de l'action
publique et l'action publique ne
fonctionne pas bien alors je veux
dire ce qui est la vérité que je
constate tous les jours
le président de la République depuis
qu'il est élu
c'est la question qu'il le travaille le
plus
et au fond cette question qui consiste à
dire mais voyons
les richesses elles sont sur le terrain
les capacités elles sont sur le terrain
les possibilités d'innovation elles sont
sur le terrain pourquoi est-ce qu'en
haut on les entend jamais et le grand
débat c'était ça et le CNR le Conseil
national de la refondation dont il m'a
confié une part de la responsabilité
c'est ça c'est allons voir sur le
terrain si on peut débloquer les choses
qui a des idées pour que ça marche mieux
sans qu'on leur oppose constamment la
circulaire la norme l'obligation la
hiérarchie le chose qui bloque il y a un
potentiel formidable et ce potentiel
formidable ne demande je le crois moi
qu'à être débloqué
et si nous débloquons l'action publique
alors il faut que nous débloquions aussi
la démocratie les règles de la
démocratie dans notre pays
cette exigence de changement
comme vous savez elle a fait l'objet de
multiples promesses et il importe de
passer des promesses à la réalisation et
[Musique]
et quelque chose s'est passé
Marc l'a évoqué et nous étions deux
Hervé Hayet quelque chose s'est passé
c'est que
le président de la République a réuni à
Saint-Denis les responsables les chefs
comme on dit de partis politiques et
c'était je suis sûr qu'il y avait de me
démentira pas c'était extraordinaire
comme moment pour deux raisons la
première c'est que ils se sont
découverts entre eux ils se
connaissaient pas
ils ont tout d'un coup découvert qui
était le celui dont il voyait la photo
dont il détestait la présence et ils se
sont écoutés et ça a été quelque chose
alors
comme le président de la République
saitifaire il a fait un marathon de 12
heures
et quand vous êtes 12 heures
bloqué dans la même pièce
quelle que soit votre
mauvaise ou bonne volonté vous êtes bien
obligé à un moment donné de regarder les
autres et de les écouter
et c'était très surprenant parce que des
gens totalement opposés en venaient à
dire des choses assez semblables et à
découvrir
dans les yeux de l'autre que peut-être
leur thèse était pas aussi favorable
qu'ils imaginaient
quand vous aviez partie d'extrême gauche
qui plaidait pour le référendum en
abaissant les signatures et qu'il
découvrait que tel autre responsable de
l'extrême droite plaider aussi pour
abaisser les signatures dans la tête de
chacun des intervenants il y avait
est-ce que je suis absolument sûr que ce
que je plaide va dans mon sens et pas
dans le sien
et c'était n'est-ce pas Hervé j'ai pas
je dis pas de bêtises c'était de ce
point de vue là infiniment troublant et
alors on se dit bon c'est une réunion
comme d'habitude va pas y avoir de suite
et bien moi je dis que désormais on est
certain ou on devrait être certain qu'il
va y avoir une suite parce que quand sur
les questions essentielles dont je vais
dire un mot
la loi électorale la proportionnelle le
les lois des collectivités locales le
référendum quand on a dit qu'on allait
se saisir de ces questions et que le
Président de la République on va faire à
dire on va faire ça dans des commissions
transpartisades
tout le monde a compris que c'était pour
laisser faire ou ne pas faire à d'autres
mais là quand il convoque les chefs de
parties et que il leur dit ben c'est
dans notre périmètre alors on va s'en
occuper et moi je vais vous dire ce que
je suggère dans ton occupe
premièrement la loi électorale et la
proportionnelle ça n'est pas possible
qu'en France il y est une loi qui fait
que
un très grand le suffrage d'un très
grand nombre d'électeurs n'est pas pris
en compte nous nous défendons le droit
de tous les électeurs à être entendus et
représenté dans les assemblées non pas
accidentellement une année mais pour
tout l'avenir parce que la loi
électorale juste c'est la reconnaissance
du pluralisme et l'obligation je vais
essayer de vous le montrer de travailler
ensemble
et donc
nous sommes
défenseurs d'un
recréation de la loi électorale il y a
deux systèmes au moins celui qui avait
été adopté Jean-Yves pour les élections
de 1986 qui était la proportionnelle
départementale il y a un autre système
tout à fait adaptable qui est le système
allemand c'est-à-dire on vote dans des
circonscriptions et en même temps on
organise la représentation de ceux qui
n'ont pas gagné dans les
circonscriptions
et ceci est très très important
l'objection à la proportionnelle elle
est faite par des gens qui disent c'est
la quatrième République on peut pas s'en
sortir et en vérité en France ce n'est
pas possible en France
de Gaulle qui était
assez génial dans ces affaires à penser
qui avait un moyen d'échapper à la
division
c'est l'élection du Président de la
République suffrage universel c'est lui
qui a la charge de concilier et de
réconcilier les opinions pour constituer
des gouvernements cohérents et pour
faire en sorte que soit gouverner un
pays
représenté dans sa diversité
et ceci fait que les objections à ce
système n'existeront plus et d'ailleurs
si on réfléchit une seconde s'il y avait
eu la proportionnelle on n'aurait pas du
tout l'assemblée qu'on a sous les yeux
parfois les gens disent mais vous l'avez
la proportionnelle regardez pas du tout
parce que des forces politiques qui ont
été obligées de se présenter ensemble
quoi qu'elle ne partage aucune idée
ce serait présenté séparément chacune
sous ses couleurs on aurait eu la
diversité de la représentation et ça
aurait permis de conforter la certitude
que mesdames et messieurs quoi qu'il en
soit vous devrez travailler ensemble
et c'est ça que nous voulons c'est que
le pluralisme soit effectif et qu'on
soit obligé d'envisager
obligation qu'on soit obligé d'envisager
de pouvoir travailler et réfléchir et
gouverner ensemble
deuxièmement il y a un deuxième sujet
que je voulais mettre sur la table
ça n'est pas possible qu'on conserve la
loi électorale de Paris Lyon et
Marseille c'est pas possible qu'on est
les trois plus grandes villes de France
qui soient gouvernés par des mères qui
ne sont pas élus par le suffrage
universel
[Applaudissements]
toutes les autres villes élisent leur
mère de Guidel à Pau en passant par
Angers puisque maintenant la plus grande
ville moderne de France c'est Angers
j'en ai un peu souffert mais enfin je
suis très content de de saluer Angers
dans nos dans les villes que dont nous
avons la responsabilité Jean-Marc
Verchère qui est un ami de toujours non
mais je dis Angers c'est plus grand ou
plus grand que pour encore aujourd'hui
ça va pas durer longtemps mais
et donc
et donc vous avez vu les résultats du
foot non rien oublier ce que je dis hier
soir et donc c'est très
c'est très important que nous allions
dans ce sens-là je souhaiterais aussi
qu'on traite des régions parce qu'il y a
pas un électeur qui connaissent son
corps ses conseillers régionaux et ça
pose un problème qui est assez sérieux
pour une démocratie
voilà les chantiers que nous avons
devant nous nous allons
aborder des élections très importantes
qui sont les élections européennes je
veux dire quelque chose nous allons les
aborder dans un climat qui est
totalement inédit dans la politique
française
avant quand on allait aux élections
européennes
c'était avec
une réticence générale des concurrents
les europhobes et les eurosceptiques
tenaient le haut du pavé et nous qui
sommes engagés pour l'Europe on avait
bien du mal contre les contre les
diffamations et les injures à défendre
l'idée européenne cette fois-ci c'est
fini cette fois-ci tout a changé et
comme ça a été rappelé si l'on regarde
le choc climatique que nous avons devant
nous si on regarde la guerre en Ukraine
si on regarde la guerre de l'énergie
la crise de l'inflation
le déclenchement par Poutine de
d'un manquement
à la règle absolue qui avait fait la
paix en Europe depuis 45 et qui était
l'intangibilité des frontières
sur le ministre de la défense des
Affaires étrangères ce jour-là Poutine a
créé la débâcle dans une guerre dans une
règle absolue et on l'a vu au Carambar
et en craint de le voir en Arménie pour
laquelle il faut il est nécessaire que
nous mobilisions toutes nos forces quand
on regarde la fracture ouverte au sein
de la société américaine
quand des gens défendent la
bipolarisation je veux les inviter à
aller voir ce qui se passe aux
États-Unis parce que vous avez deux
parties et selon la règle de Bayrou que
vous connaissez bien les parties se
tiennent par leur noyau dur
et donc la bipolarisation c'est
l'affrontement des plus radicaux de la
droite contre les plus radicaux de la
gauche
et nous nous considérons que ceci est
une malédiction
et que la société américaine est menacée
dans son existence et dans son avenir
parce qu'il se passe politiquement par
l'exacerbation des conflits et des
haines quand on regarde la remise en
cause que vit la Chine
la remise en cause du des principes même
du commerce mondial avec un nouveau
protectionnisme auquel il faut que nous
soyons attentifs et peut-être acteur
quand on regarde les tremblements de
terre que politique que connaît le
continent africain le Moyen-Orient le
Liban les vagues d'intégrisme et les
vagues d'immigrations tout ça n'a qu'une
réponse possible c'est l'existence la
puissance et la solidarité de l'Europe
et il n'y a qu'un courant d'opinion qui
défendent la puissance l'existence et la
société de l'Europe c'est le nôtre c'est
ce qui constitue
ceux qui ont constitué l'ensemble qui a
permis l'élection du Président de la
République qui forme la majorité
d'aujourd'hui et qui seront donc pour la
première fois de notre histoire
électorale sans aucun complexe devant
des attaques
les anti-européens je les invite à aller
voir Madame Mélanie
madame Meloni elle se fait élire contre
l'Europe
en disant les questions d'immigration je
vais les régler toute seule avec
l'Italie et ces questions d'immigration
là
l'Europe n'aura plus rien à y voir il ne
sait pas passer une année sans qu'elle
fasse appel au secours sans que
constatant son impuissance elle se
tourne vers le sol recours possible
niant absolument son engagement et je
les invite à aller voir les partisans du
brexit
un ceux qui disaient pas de problème
parce que nous allons reprendre le
contrôle
de notre pays de notre histoire de notre
destin tout va aller mieux et notamment
l'immigration c'est la crise économique
c'est la crise du niveau de vie c'est la
crise de l'emploi et c'est une
immigration multipliée par deux
depuis la sortie de la Grande-Bretagne
et donc nous avons désormais toutes les
raisons et toutes les certitudes pour
défendre cette construction en cours que
nous essayons d'améliorer d'inspirer
mais qui est désormais le seul recours
possible pour un peuple et je suis sûr
que les Français ne s'y tromperont pas
et dont les élections européennes sont
bienvenus voilà ce que je suis certain
que nous allons défendre dans les mois
qui viennent
tout cela pour moi ça n'est pas autre
chose que le plus profond de notre
engagement pas d'un engagement politique
seulement d'un engagement
du fond de ce que nous sommes de ce
qu'est la France
engagement du projet français et si vous
me permettez d'employer un mot qui est
pas très
usité habituellement je crois que c'est
l'engagement de l'âme française que nous
trouvons devant nous
la France qui est j'avais autrefois
défini
la France comme communauté de destin
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire communauté de
destin
alors que j'avais défini l'Europe comme
communauté de civilisations que ça veut
dire communauté de destin ça veut dire
que
votre
identité
elle n'est pas dans le passé
elle est un peu dans l'histoire de
chacun mais l'identité française c'est
pas une question de race c'est pas une
question de couleur de peau c'est pas
une question de religion c'est une
question de projet partagé et c'est ce
projet là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le triptyque
liberté égalité fraternité
c'est toujours été frappé que c'était
pas une bipolarisation
liberté égalité fraternité
on peut tout à fait défendre la liberté
en se moquant de l'égalité
chacun pour soi il y a des gens qui
pensent ça
on peut tout à fait défendre l'égalité
en se moquant de la liberté on va mettre
des normes on va mettre des règles on va
obliger les gens à plier les chines et
tous ceux qui sort par exemple les
ennemis c'est les riches
bon ça c'est ça c'est la bipolarisation
et nous nous sommes au fond du côté de
la fraternité et pourquoi nous sommes du
côté de la fraternité on y pense jamais
parce que la fraternité ne peut pas elle
se concevoir sans liberté et sans
égalité
si vous n'avez pas la liberté l'égalité
vous pouvez pas avoir de fraternité
c'est pourquoi nous sommes
allés la clé de voûte dans cette famille
politique de l'engagement des citoyens
français au service de l'âme de la
France et donc pour moi les mois qui
viennent sont pleins d'espoir et il est
de notre devoir de le transmettre à la
société française
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais dire un mot en finissant de
ceux qui nous attendent dans les
semaines qui viennent
nous allons vivre une épreuve
injuste
à bien des égards scandaleuses
pour une formation politique qui a fait
de la moralisation de la vie publique
sont principales axe d'engagement et son
mantra depuis des années
je veux vous dire deux choses et en
pensant à tous ceux qui
parmi nous vont affronter cette épreuve
et à ceux et celles qui seront pas là
pour la santé
je vais vous dire que 1 il n'est pas
vrai que nous ayons en quoi que ce soit
participer au moindre détournement dont
nous sommes accusés et qui se sont
effondrés les unes après les autres par
l'enquête elle est même et par
l'instruction elle-même ce n'est pas
vrai
alors quand vous êtes certain que ce
n'est pas vrai alors un procès
finalement
c'est un moment de libération et
j'espère qu'on va le vivre comme ça et
la deuxième chose quand
ça sera dur si c'est dur je penserai à
vous et ça va être précieux merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant en allemand
[Applaudissements]